foreign
[Applause]
the photog frenzy was nothing but civil
as Harrison Ford cracks that whip one
last time as Indiana Jones
the warmth of this place the sense of
community unimaginable and it makes me
feel good
the Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny World premiere an emotional
Harrison was presented with an honorary
Palm Door award and thanked wife kalista
Flockhart my life has been enabled by
my lovely wife
of course
supported my passion and the doting
husband became an instant meme thanks to
his loving look in this behind the
scenes shot one person said quote this
picture deserves an Oscar the film hits
theaters June 30th and will also
introduce several new characters I'm
retiring well in that case what are we
drinking Bibi Waller bridge is the
female lead but not a love interest
playing Dr Jones goddaughter Helena
there's anybody now at the time remember
again what's a huge uh franchise it is
some of the film takes place in 1944
about eight years after 1981's Raiders
of the Lost Ark so the now 80 year old
had to be aged down Dr Jones and I know
that that is my face that's what I
looked like 35 years ago but I don't
look back and say I wish I was a guy
again I'm real happy with age I think
you're still very hot we was stunned to
see you take your shirt off
blessed with this body
thanks for noticing
[Music]